>> Alright Sam, I'm ready let's build this app. What do we do?
>> So the first thing we need to do is
think about what do we care about most at a festival.
>> Okay I mean we're paying attention, mostly I guess, to the bands.
>> Mm-hm.
>> the stages they're playing on and the people who are going.
>> Right.
>> That sound about right?
>> Yeah, those are the main things we want to track. Let's write it
down on this tablet and kind of map out what our schema is going to be.
>> Okay.
>> First, we start off with our festival.
One of the other things you said we wanted to track, were
bands. Also, we wanted to track stages, and we wanted to track attendees.
>> Okay, so, you've written these words.
is there any particular reason why you did
it the way you did? Like in these boxes, or any reason for the structure?
>> So I think the boxes will become
a little more apparent when we go into the
app to start building. But for now, I mean,
it's pretty simple. We'll build up more later but
really, it'll become a little more interesting
when we actually start connecting the boxes and
talking about how do festivals relate to
bands, or how do attendees relate to festivals.
>> Okay, cool. so I, I, should we start building it? What do we have to do?
>> Yeah, let's go in the browser.
>> Okay.